We are on problem number 14.
See, what did they draw here?
That's the y-axis, that's
the x-axis.
They drew a line that looks
something like this.
Let's see, negative 3, so it
goes something like this.
That's close enough.
And then they're saying that
this is the point negative 3.
This is the point y
equals negative 1.
This is of course the y-axis.
This is the x-axis.
The figure above shows a graph
of the line of y equals mx
plus b, where m and
b are constants.
Which of the following best
represents the graph of y is
equal to minus 3mx plus b?
Well, if this yellow line-- this
is y equals mx plus b.
Well, what is b, first of all?
b is just the y-intercept.
So the y-intercept is right
here, y equals negative 1.
So b is negative 1.
And what's the slope?
Well, when we run, that's
what-- 1, 2, 3 units.
Change in x is 3.
What is the rise?
The rise, we go down,
so it's negative 1.
We go down 1.
So the change in y is
equal to negative 1.
So the slope is negative 1/3.
So the equation of this
line is y is equal to
minus 1/3 x minus 1.
So if you want to know what
minus 3mx plus b is, what's
minus 3 times this m?
What's minus 3 times
minus 1/3?
Well, the negatives cancel out,
so you just get-- let me
switch to purple, because that's
that problem-- minus 3
times-- this is m, right?
This is m.
So minus 3 times minus 1/3,
that just equals 1.
So it equals 1x plus b.
What's b?
It's minus 1.
So the graph we're looking
for is x minus 1.
And so if we wanted to draw
that, the y-intercept would be
the same, it would
be right there.
And then you just have
a slope of 1.
Slope of 1 looks-- well, that's
as close as I could do
to drawing it, right--
that's a slope of 1.
Your change in x should be the
same as your change in y.
So if you look at all the
choices, first of all, it's
pretty obvious it's
D, I think.
And they make it very explicit
that the slope is 1 and the
y-intercept is negative 1.
And that's choice D.
Next problem.
I get excited when there's
something to draw, because we
can get through them faster.
15.
If the volume of a cube is 8,
what is the shortest distance
from the center of the cube
to the base of the cube?
Fascinating.
So the volume is 8,
so what are the
dimensions of this cube?
It's a cube, so all the sides
are the same, right?
So x times x times x is x to the
third, and that equals 8.
So the dimensions-- what to
the third power is 8?
You should know that.
2, right?
2 times 2 times 2 is 8.
So the dimensions of the
cube are 2 by 2 by 2.
So let's take that cross section
where the center is.
And if I were to draw it, so
that's just-- so the center of
the cube is right here.
And we know the dimensions
of this cross section.
It's 2, 2, 2, 2.
Right?
I just sliced the cube
right there.
And I just want to make sure
I'm doing this problem.
From the center of the cube to
the base of the cube-- so the
base of the cube is going to
be-- if I were to draw the
cube, this would have been the
base of the cube down here.
So this is the base
of the cube.
So they're essentially just
asking us, what's this
distance right here?
Well that's easy.
This is the center, so
it's right in the
middle, so it's 1. soon.
It's 1 to the bottom, it's 1 to
the roof of the cube, it's
1 to each of the sides.
So it's 1 away.
So that is answer A.
Next problem.
Problem 16.
If y is equal to 5x cubed over
z, what happens to the value
of y when both x and
z are doubled?
So the way I think about it
is, y is equal to 5x cubed
divided by z.
Actually do you know what the
very easiest way to do this
problem is?
Substitute numbers
for x and z.
So let's say that x is equal
to 1 and z equals to 1.
So in this situation,
y is equal to what?
5 times 1 cubed divided by 1,
well that's just equal to 5.
Now they're saying,
what happens
if x and z are doubled?
So let's take the second
situation.
x is equal to 2, z
is equal to 2.
Now, y is equal to 5 times
2 cubed over 2.
And that is equal to what?
Well, 2 cubed divided by 2, this
2 cancels with the cubed.
You get 2 squared.
So it's just 5 times 2 squared,
which is 5 times 4,
which is 20.
So y went from 5 to 20, so y
increased by a factor of 4.
And that is choice E.
y is multiplied by 4.
These questions can be
surprisingly confusing because
you're like, oh, you have these
variables, do you make x
into 2x and z into 2z,
and then solve for--
just try out numbers.
They're not putting any
restrictions on you, so just
substitute x and z, 1 and
1, and then double them.
Next problem.
The SAT, speed matters more
than maybe rigor.
All right.
Problem 17.
Luke purchased an automobile
for $5,000.
And the value of the automobile
decreased by 20% per year.
The value in dollars of the
automobile n years from the
date of the purchase is given by
the function v, where v of
n is equal to 5,000 times 4/5,
which is the same thing as
0.8, to the nth power.
Fair enough.
How many years from the date of
the purchase will the value
of the automobile be $3,200?
Well, they're saying the
value is $3,200, so we
just solve for n.
v of how many years is
equal to $3,200?
3,200 is equal to 5,000
times 4/5 to the n.
Divide both sides by 5,000, you
get 3,200/5,000 is equal
to 4/5 to the n.
And then, let's see,
what's 32/5,000?
You can delete these 0's.
Let's see, 16/25.
That equals-- so 16/25 is
equal to 4/5 to the n.
And we should immediately--
well, hopefully you'd
recognize is that 16 is 4
squared, and 25 is 5 squared,
so 16/25 is equal
to 4/5 squared.
4 squared is 16.
5 squared is 25.
So n is equal to 2.
2 years.
And that is choice B.
Let's see if I have time for--
no, we have a couple more
problems. I'll do
the last three
problems in the next video.
I will see you